no
[Music]
Victorian house
tired just got kicked out from the
surgery
[Music]
good morning currently I'm in a fairly
rural part of England for my anesthetics
placement at Medical School by the way
anesthetics is a specialty medicine that
gives drugs to patients to prevent pain
during surgeries or procedures as with
all medical schools we're having to
travel to different hospitals for
different Specialties and the anesthesia
block that I'm on right now lasts for
two weeks which means I'm going to be
away from home in the middle of nowhere
for the next two weeks now let's plan a
day ahead and get some work done before
we head to hospital
foreign
[Music]
unfortunately I don't bring much food
with me from home so I only have a
limited Supply and it should last me for
the week so the food I'll be eating
during my stay here won't be so crazy
thank you
baby
[Music]
in the morning we had basic life support
or CPR training from the resuscitation
team then I head upstairs and went on a
mission to find the perfect set of
mismatching Scrubs and after wrestling
with my hair claw for what felt like an
eternity I was finally transformed into
a surgical Fashionista
[Music]
just got kicked out from the surgery so
now I'm going to go have some lunch
[Music]
salmon yeah it's good it looks like some
kind of chicken dish right what'd you
guys think about hospital food in
general yeah I had to get it because I
don't have enough food at home yeah
bring so much food
we're seeing in a really nice house guys
just like an old Victorian it's like wow
that was yours
[Music]
I haven't started at all
we have time I guess okay
wait like I'm okay no I get confused as
well no yeah one of them
this moment that he knew he followed oh
my god wow
[Music]
it's currently seven to three in the
afternoon and I'm going to go to library
to look up the notes of the patients
that I saw this morning
sorry also there is some building work
going on in the hospital so I'm not sure
if you can hear me but the patient that
I saw this morning was really sick he
had this intra-abdominal sepsis which
means a huge infection in your tummy so
hope he got out of the surgery okay then
I'm going to write up a case-based
discussion on that patient to present to
the anesthetist consultant on Thursday
[Music]
thank you
just got out of the hospital now I'm
walking back to the Airbnb because my
place and partner finished before me and
she drove there already but it's not too
bad because it's only 25 minutes walk
foreign
[Music]
honestly I was super hungry I couldn't
wait until I get home so I had to get
some snacks from the corner shop and I'm
not regressing it's pretty good
[Music]
I'm super tired
I don't even have energy to eat I just
want to get in my bed and have a nap and
I might do that actually
[Music]
just finished my nap
and
okay
[Applause]
these are all the ingredients I have
what's enough
[Music]
now that I'm in perfect form after
getting a good nap and a mediocre dinner
I can finally get some work done
honestly being away from home for
Hospital placements and traveling far
away are my least favorite parts of
medical school because your whole
routine gets disrupted but when I treat
it as a small holiday it's actually
enjoyable currently I'm working on this
essay deadline for next week and it's
part of our special study unit my topic
is on stigma and taboo surrounding
patients with learning disabilities
[Music]
I've just started reading this book it's
called the four hour work week by Tim
Ferriss one of my favorite YouTubers
posted this on his Instagram and I find
it quite inspirational so far so I
thought I'd make the most of this huge
old Victorian house by reading this book
in different parts of the house
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed this consider
subscribing and I'll see in the next one
bye